الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
ولكن ماذا عن اخباره لين تبعها معا بي
ايجاز من غرفه اخبار الجزيره معاي انا
محمد بنزيما كنتم حياكم الله
من الولايات المتحده حيث يستمر فرز
الاصوات في الانتخابات النصفيه
الى تقدم الحزب الجمهوري في مجلس النواب
واحتدام المنافسه في مجلس الشيوخ الذي
ستحللون نتائج ولايه نيفادا من يفوز بها
لنسال الزميل عثمان فرح عن توقعات الشارع
الامريكي لنتائج يا مرحبا عثمان
هل كانت هذه النتائج التي صدرت حتى اللحظه
متوقعه نعم محمد النتائج المتوقعه وغير
متوقع هي متوقعه لان الرئيس عاده حزبه
يخسر الانتخابات النصفيه في بدايه عهده
وبالتالي يخسر الديمقراطيون مجلس النواب
ولكن هي غير متوقعه لان الاستطلاعات كانت
تقول ان الحزب الجمهوري سيحقق نتائج كبيره
او موجه حمراء كما توصف وهو ما لم يحدث
رغم تدني شعبيه الرئيس
الجمهوريون فازوا في مجلس النواب ولكن ليس
بكثير وظل السباق محتدما في مجلس الشيوخ
حتى اخر
يعطيك الصحه عثمان من امريكا الى اوروبا
وتوتر في الشارع حيث شهدت الدول الاوروبيه
عند مظاهرات واضرافات عامه شلت قطاعات
حيويه احتجاجا على تدن الاجور وللمطالبه
بمواجهه التضخم في باريس اصاب شلل حركه
النقل العام بسبب الاضراب الذي دعت اليه
النقابات العماليه وهو ما تسبب في التعطل
الكبير لحركه السكان والسوريه لكن ما الذي
اوصل اوروبا الى هذه الازمه يا ترى تحكي
عن الاقتصاد وبيجي مباشره
محمد السبب الرئيسي هو ارتفاع الضغط طبعا
التضخم للناس اكثر هو ارتفاع بلدان الطاقه
بسبب الحرب الروسيه همم على اوكرانيا
والحظر والطاقه الروسيه ثاني شيء هو همم
موضوع الغذاء
الغذاء فلما عنصرين غذاء بطاقه رفع من
كلفه معيشه الاوروبيين اللي بدفعوا ضرائب
كثير بالاصل فهاي زادت من وطئتها عليهم
فخرجوا للشارع في محاوله انه يرفعوا
اجاراتهم بمقدار التضخم الان التضخم هو في
اعلى مستوياته في اوروبا منطقه اليورو
تقريبا 10% هذه مستويات تعتبر رهيبه اذا
ما اضفناها الى كم المسؤوليات والضغط على
المواطن همم شكرا نادين
المره الجايه شكرا جزيلا هو في اخبارنا
هذا الاسبوع لاخر يتطورات الحدث الكروي
الاهم كاس العالم 20 22 تفاعل واسمه
فلسطين تنور الدوحه على المنصه ترحبا
بالمشجعين الفلسطينيين القديمين الى
الدوحه حضورك كاس العالم وذلك بعد اعلان
الفيفا الاتفاق على تشغيل رحلات طيران
مؤقته بين تل ابيب والدوحه خلال مده
البطوله ستتيح للجماهير الفلسطينيه
والاسرائيليه حضور المونديال من خلالها
بشرط ان لا يجري نقلهم بطيران اسرائيلي
وقلم مسؤول قطريين الدوحه ابلغت اسرائيل
ان اي تصعيد في القدس او غزه او الضفه
الغربيه خلال المونديال يمكن اي يؤديه الى
الغاء الاتفاق بما في ذلك الرحلات الجويه
المباشره على المنصات لقي القرار تفاعلا
واسعا لنقرا لكم بعض التغريدات هنا موسى
تقول قضيه فلسطين هي قضيه العرب الاولى
وكل ما ارادوا لها ان تخبث
نهضت من جديد تخصيص دوله قطر الاف المقاعد
في بطوله كاس العالم لابناء فلسطين هي
لفتاه كريمه وذكيه تتيح لهم الحضور
بهويتهم الاصليه وتتغلب بها على ازواجيه
الغرب
وربيبته اسرائيل اما لبنى فتقول كميه
الفرحه اللي بداخلي بسبب اصول الفلسطينيين
الاراضي القطريه لا توصف وعلى صعيد سياسي
اخر مرتبط بالمونديال رفضت الفيفا ارتداء
قمصان التدريب الخاصه بمنتخب الدنمارك
بسبب شعار سياسي اذ حملت القمصان وشعاره
حقوق الانسان للجميع الذي قبل بالرفض من
قبل الفيفا لانه مخالف لقوانين ولوحي
الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم وفي خبر احزنا
الكثيرين قبل ايام من قليله من بدء
المونديال قالت صحيفه الفرنسيه ساديو ماني
قائد المنتخب السنغالي سيغيب عن المونديال
ذلك بسبب الاصابه في حين اعلن مدرب هو
المنتخب
استدعاء نجم منتخب بلاده وذلك على الرغم
من اصابته وهو ما اثر حقوقا وتساؤلات بشان
مشاركته في العرس الكروي العالمي دقائق
قليله تفصلنا عن بدايه النشره الرياضيه
ساستغل هذه الفرصه لاتوجه الى زميل حمزه
الراضي لن نساله عن قضيه ساديو ماني الذي
يراه هنا في الخلفيه صحيح يا حمزه نعم
مرحبا محمد خبر اصابه ساديو ماني نزل
كسائق اليس فقط على جمهور السنغال ولا
ولكن على مستوى العالم لما يحظى بهذا
النجم الكبير من احترام وتقدير الجميع ليس
فقط داخل رقعه الميدان ولكن ايضا كسفير
للعمل الخير والانساني في العديد من
المبادرات التي قام بها لكن استدعاءه من
قبل المدرب اليوسسي ربما اعاد الفرحه
لعشاق هذا النجم الكبير وعلى في اسوء
الاحوال سيكون ساديو ماني حاضر في
المباراه الثالثه او في الدور الثاني في
حال ما تاهل المنتخب شكرا حمزه اتركك
لتبدا النشره بعد دقائق فقط من الان نحن
نذهب الى الخبر الاخير في اجازنا الاسبوعي
همم سرحت همم شركه اخرى تعرفون خبر
التويتر قامت بتسريح نصف عدد موظف فيها
خلال همم يعني سابقه ولكن هناك شركه اخرى
فعلت الامر ذاته شركه ميتا الملكه لفيسبوك
وواتساب وانستغرام تسير على الخطه نفسها
وتعلن انهاء خدمتي اكثر من احد عشر الفا
من موظفيها ياتي ذلك في وقت تشهد فيه منصه
ازمه بسبب تخفيضات في ميزانيه المعلمين في
ظل معاناتهم لتضخم وارتفاع يسعر الفائده
برايكم في ظل هذه التطورات من الصلاه
التواصل الى اين تشاركونا ارائكم في
التعليقات التقي بكم الاسبوع المقبل في
الاجازه حياكم الله
[موسيقى]